episode 5 of The Last of Us has a
perfect blend of deviations and
faithfulness to the source material it
does enough new to completely enhance
the original while not going too far to
the point of making it unrecognizable
episode 3 was my favorite but I can see
why some people may dislike that episode
because of how much of a departure it
was from the game among other reasons
too but episode 5 I feel like we'll gain
the mass appeal because the changes that
were made were absolutely insane the
entire action set piece that resembles
hardhome from Game of Thrones was
basically entirely original besides the
sniper standoff that was the one shared
aspect so first let's talk about these
big changes and how genius it was
overall because I think this episode is
an improvement over the game action wise
the undead Massacre is such an
adrenaline feeling moment that I was in
shock about how amazing the scene was
from the spectacle of the explosion to
then revealing the sinkhole that is
perfectly timed writing wise to
coincidle the encounter with Henry the
gradual oh [__] moment that slowly
builds as we hear the infected
thundering footsteps approached our
characters was great also I love how the
sound drops out just before they emerge
it gives off this erupting feeling along
with having some orgasmic payoff
then the absolute Chaos on in series
when the infected start to swarm
everyone is an action wet dream just
having dozens of people laying into a
horde of zombies with assault rifles is
metal as hell and further throws the
excitement factor of this scene into the
heavens along with this portraying the
infected as extremely powerful and
menacing that's something that I love
about the show so far the writers have
been very particular as to when they
have scenes with the infected so that
they can preserve their intimidation
because if you have too many scenes of
Joel killing clickers then you start to
lose the impact and scare factor of the
undead since they don't pose much of a
threat anymore like the first few scenes
we have so far with them have all been
terrifying and our characters are always
on the verge of death This Feeling of no
plot armor is outstanding and feels rare
nowadays because it's really hard to
realistically raise the danger while not
compromising the logic and having your
characters actually survive without the
intervention of the writer Gods the only
aspect within this action set piece that
relates to this point that partially
bothered me was the fact that Joel never
missed the clickers all of these shots
seem pretty hard to execute especially
since he was having trouble earlier but
I can't buy it because it's definitely
possible for Joel to succeed here going
back to some of the things I loved about
this scene is the editing if you think
about it we have three different
perspectives running around this mosh
bit of clickers and at no point does it
ever feel jarring or incoherent every
shot feels very purposeful as to the
flow of the scene an example of this is
Joel shooting a clicker that's
approaching Ellie and Henry which then
pairs their two perspectives together
now the edit is primarily focusing on
telling their story until getting to a
good stopping point in their micro
Journey Through the scene like when
Ellie gets into the car and achieves her
temporary goal of getting to shelter
then we cut to some brief shots of
people getting wrecked to increase the
Panic which is followed by the next
micro story beat like with the bloater
emerging pacing wise this is perfect and
I just love the structure throughout the
scene then another clever thing is that
the editor chooses to ramp up the number
of cuts whenever our characters are in
Mortal danger this form of editing
increases the anxiety of the viewer and
further makes you relate to the state of
panic that our characters are enduring
and then some of the other shots we are
allowed to view for a longer duration
like I just love this wide shot of the
clickers initially pouring out of the
sinkhole and witnessing all the
destruction it gives you a great grasp
as to the insane scale of the scene and
it creates a first impression of being
stunned by what's transpiring also while
on the subject of editing there was this
one shot of Perry where it's his
reaction shot to the bloater yelling the
editor here opts to slow down the
footage but since they probably shot it
at 24 frames a second it becomes a quick
slide show and it is very noticeable it
just seems a little odd to slow it down
here in an otherwise really well edited
scene because if they didn't shoot it at
a very high frame rate that actually
allows you to slow down footage given
the extra frames then it sticks out like
a sore thumb looking at some other key
moments from the this scene I love how
the bloater is introduced here in the
show because in the game it was
introduced on completely different terms
and also much earlier in the story I
would talk about it a bit but I feel
like that would just be spoilers for the
game at this point however the terms in
which it's introduced in the game I
don't think is as crazy or as Grand as
it is here in the show the execution of
the bloater was perfect and the entire
essence of him being like a leader of
sorts reminded me of the night king
during hardhome the sound design of his
Bassy auroras were chilling and the fact
that they brought in the death
animations into the show where he ripped
Perry's head off was a nice touch
another standout moment to me was the
child clicker in the car with Ellie like
you think that this scene couldn't get
even more tense and then we had this
little isolated encounter as this
demented clicker is folding over seats
like a noodle then the fact that the
same clicker ends up killing Kathleen is
both a great action and writing moment
it's deeply ironic how she was
threatening and wanting to kill the kids
to then getting killed by one along with
her ignoring the festering issue of the
clickers in the tunnel in the pursuit of
Henry so it ends up biting her in the
ass narratively I think Kathleen was
done great Justice in this episode she
wasn't very compelling in the one prior
but through her backstory finding out
that her brother was originally the
leader and that responsibility was kind
of passed on to her makes sense along
with her essentially fitting the mold of
being a ruthless leader and not being
afraid of killing people it just made
her first scene feel a little
contradictory where she's breaking up
when faced with killing this person she
has a minor connection to to then
condemning all these people to die I
know she doesn't have to kill them
herself but she's still the one who's
ordering it also this moment where she's
trying to question these prisoners feels
like she's speaking with the same
Cadence of a kindergarten teacher
addressing their class when they did
something bad
did it make you feel better
did it make you feel safe
how does it make you feel now
so I still wish they made Kathleen a bit
more intimidating because the writing
surrounding her character is really
solid in the larger context like giving
a perspective to this group was a great
way to have a better action
confrontation at the end of the episode
and one that had significantly more
payoff that's one of the biggest
improvements so far from the video game
I know some people were annoyed that the
last episode had to do some actual build
up that requires time but I think it was
definitely worth it in the long run and
the idea that people were floating that
these two episodes should have been
combined I don't think would have worked
for two main reasons firstly the last
episode had a great end point for Joel
and Ellie's relationship and Henry
showing up was a good Cliffhanger
opportunity the second reason has to do
with Henry's perspective prior to
meeting Joel if he were to jump to this
flashback right after this confrontation
it would have felt much more jarring
than having it separated by two
different episodes because episode 5 is
more about Henry and Sam than it is
about Joel and Ellie Joel and Ellie are
still definitely prominent but the
writers opt to give more development to
Henry and Sam so they're depressing and
heartbreaking demise hits even harder
like you may identify their opening
scenes as not really being integral to
the plot but I think they were necessary
in setting up the bond between these two
brothers the scene in the Attic where
Henry tries to brighten up Sam's mood
was very wholesome and instantly makes
you love them I adore how the music here
is able to flourish uninterrupted
audio-wise because these two characters
are communicating via signing it allows
the music to resonate more with you and
deaf characters I feel like have to rely
a lot more on facial and bodily
performances which is the root of acting
and I love that making Sam a deaf
character was a brilliant change and as
I said in the behind the scenes this
aspect makes Sam even more reliant on
Henry it's a quick and efficient way to
bring them closer together and it works
with no Faults although I wouldn't have
minded if they leans a bit more on Sam's
deafness within a zombie apocalypse like
maybe having a moment where he's
approached by a clicker without him
noticing and having to be saved by Henry
or something but regardless Sam and
Henry were still Flawless throughout the
whole episode not even in terms of
writing because they both did an
incredible job in the acting departments
Lamar Johnson as Henry in particular
really blew me away every scene he was
in he was very charismatic and he always
had this air of Innocence to him he's
very honest and genuine and Lamar
Johnson has a warm factor that exudes
from him in almost every moment he just
comes across as so likable and relatable
to the point that you're always
sympathizing with what he has to say
also the writers even gave Henry more of
a backstory here to further humanize him
expanding Henry's backstory and
entangling it with Kathleen's is much
more interesting than what happens in
the game because there it was basically
just writers driving out Henry's group
however in the show the writers make a
tour Henry has to make the choice to
either ride out Kathleen's brother that
leads to his death or choose to get some
essential medicine for his brother this
was very smart and doesn't compromise
his character because anyone in the
situation would choose to protect their
younger brother and on the flip side if
someone was responsible for your
brother's death you'd rightfully want
them to pay this makes for a good
parallel between these two characters
and it's surprising that Craig Mason
basically came up with this on the fly
from how deep this is I just love how in
almost every Inside the episode Neil
druckman is constantly like ah I wish I
wrote that into the game and is
constantly praising Craig this kind of
bond between the original writer loving
the work of the new writer and not being
overly protective is a great pairing
that further leads to an unbelievable
result so far along with giving Neil
druckman the ability to revisit his past
work and make it even better since he's
had a lot of time to reflect on it and
think of what can be improved before
going into the final scene I'll
highlight a few other of my favorite
moments to delay the inevitable sadness
that comes with talking about the tragic
ending one moment that made me burst out
laughing was Joel's [__] voice
moments it really comes out of nowhere
without funny it is and is even better
when Joel says something else that shows
the fact that he's still really tense
and then one last moment that I'll
highlight is the gang finding that
underground classroom this scene has a
lot to offer because it allows the
innocence of Ellie to briefly resurface
because at the end of the day she's
still a kid this aspect about her
character coming out is really nice to
see because Ellie is a naturally tough
character and she is able to express
herself from a more Whimsical internal
perspective which this allows for some
great bonding moments with Sam to make
his death that much more sad for Ellie
and him along with this whole classroom
setting being interesting I wonder if
this group was initially in the tunnels
but they got royally screwed over by
fedra bringing the undead down there and
that was the reason for their downfall
this scene also allowed for Joel and
Henry to reach a better status in their
brief relationship that was really
integral for joelen being upset by
Henry's death this scene does a lot the
more you think about it while also
offering a good beat in the pacing to
slow down before they Crazy Action set
piece so let's finally get into the
emotional despair of the ending of the
episode Henry reacting to Sam being
infected was a perfect blend of
confusion upset and utter shock that it
would seem impossible to act out this
moment from how complicated the
emotional requirement is here but Lamar
Johnson blows the scene out of the water
and so does everyone else Joel and Ellie
equally matchless and it just creates a
magnificent scene that guts the audience
emotionally just this entire plot point
is so devastating because finally Joel
and Ellie have found a pairing that
they've come to enjoy but has ripped
away from them because of the nature of
the world that and Ellie trying to heal
Sam was [__] depressing and he
immediately know that's not how science
works and the fate of Sam is locked in
from that point on even playing through
the game I still feel floored by what
happened because of how amazing the
writing and acting is here then the
contrast between Joel and Ellie is
further explored here in the show where
you see Joel expressing more sorrow to
towards the two brothers while Ellie is
quick to move on it's an opposite kind
of trajectory for the two characters as
Joel learns to open up more to others
and be more caring while Ellie is
learning more from Joel and that she
needs to be more resilient to survive in
this hostile world I think this moment
in their relationship was a great little
beat and seeing it expressed through
this shot of Joel in the foreground
struck him by grief contrasted by Ellie
far away in the background out of focus
was a clever move by the DPA God just
every aspect about this show is so great
to the point that watching anything else
feels like an immediate downgrade thank
you for watching and let me know what
you thought about episode 5 of The Last
of Us
foreign